three she kept TV another loyal viewer
where's the best place to start for
start-up small business and/or new
youtubers thanks Andrea and Evan so the
first place to start you know assuming
that you've done all your due diligence
like you've identified who your target
audience is you know where they are
where they want to be in things like
that there's a couple things that you
could do I would start by taking a look
at your space that you're in and looking
at the media coverage that other people
have gotten in your space so you can see
the types of articles the types of media
that they've done and then that way you
can also see which reporters are writing
about these things so it's kind of
starting to survey the land if you will
to figure out okay who's talking about
these things that I want to be known for
and then going after those types of
reporters another thing that I would
recommend is I'm a big proponent of
establishing a platform for yourself as
a thought leader within your industry
within you know your expertise and
things like that and so you know once
you identify what your target media
publications media outlets are you know
offer to contribute an article that
showcases your expertise now an article
like this it's not going to be able to
say hey I do this and come purchase my
service or hire me but what it's going
to do is when someone is looking for a
service like yours or is looking for a
product like yours when they go to
google and those articles start coming
up best believe they're going to see
your name and oh by the way you're going
to be established as a thought leader
for another final thing that I would
recommend just kind of quick easy things
that you can do is utilize some of these
free services so help a reporter out I
don't know if you're familiar with it
but I've been using it since I've been
in PR it's the free service you sign up
for and it's basically three daily
emails that reporters is basically media
queries and so it's a whole list of
various reporters who are writing
articles and they're looking for sources
so all I do is comb through and see hey
what can a Weber comment on here what
are you know with something thats
related to what we do that we can help
this literally help this reporter out
and get an article ran so those are just
some things that I would recommend just
starting out I love it uh hero is a
great source help a reporter out
think for anybody who's trying to do
that one understand that you are an
expert you should be right as an
entrepreneur you should be an expert in
your industry what you do and for every
article that reporters writing they're
looking for experts right you read any
article they're shooting stats an
opinion and then there's always some
expert quoted right that should be you
for your industry and here was a great
free resource to use one I use as well
as called PR leads.com similar I find a
little bit higher quality publications
but there's also a cost it's ninety nine
dollars a month but I've gotten into New
York Times and Forbes because of it so
um a good investment Lisa my point of
view a tip for that would be when you're
writing to the reporter you want to you
want to write a story you don't want to
say hey I'm an expert on that happy to
talk to you because they're getting so
many people writing to them right okay
have twenty to a hundred people writing
into them to say hey I can help you out
they're going to go to the ones that
provide some values so in that email
will you reach out you want to make sure
you're giving them value and explaining
your thoughts on whatever piece that
they're writing so that makes them want
to call you yeah I would agree with that
and then another one in addition to
heroin the one that you mentioned
there's profit I don't know if you're
familiar with profinet as well that's
also a pay service but one little trick
that I found though is if you follow the
Prophet account same for Harrow even
though herro it's free but if you follow
the Prophet net account a lot of times
they'll post a lot of the queries in
Twitter so you can get you know some
free queries right there and see if
there's anything that you can add in i'm
writing this down hold on crime and
equity i'm running to and to drop into
knowledge I like it witter and I noticed
that they do post some of their queries
of reporters who are looking for things
and it's free like its Twitter so that's
cool I like it I like it I like it what
I would say is I think you should be
really active in the community that you
want to be known in so you know if
you're trying to be a successful
youtuber and you're trying to get
attention I would try to gravitate more
towards collaborations with other
youtubers people already have a YouTube
audience I think you could get more
leverage out of that that
and being featured in your local
newspaper as an example because how many
people reading the newspaper are kind of
daily YouTube viewers to the point of
knowing who your target audience is that
and you're brought up at the start of
the show I think if you promote well
within that platform and connect with
people within your platform you'll grow
much faster than if you go off platform
none of the our platform stuff doesn't
help I think you just get more success
and results from being in platform yeah
and I think it so it goes back to what
we're saying it's about you know what
your goals are so you have to identify
those that's one of the main things in
order to be successful with these things
you have to identify what your goals are
at the start it's not enough just to say
hey I want people to know who I am or I
want you no more business you have to
identify specifically where your goals
are your messages so that you can always
stay true to those and refer back to
them so that everything that you do
aligns with those goals